we're live are we all right
good afternoon everybody or good evening
whichever part of
kent you're in i suppose there's
the usual technology to start with um if
you've got any difficulties
james who is online with us um is the
democratic services technology man
if you have a complete tactic
um if you're not you please ensure that
your microphones are
and always ensure that your phones
are either turned off or turned to
silent
and i would only ask members to use the
chat function to indicate that they want
to
raise a question
are there any apologies for absence
no that's good are there any
declarations of interest
no that's even better the minutes of the
previous meeting
um could i have any comments about those
no i agree them so can i have a second
nurses
sorry exactly
yeah sorry mr chairman
um i'm sorry to say that when we
and this is perhaps for mr hughes
through you chairman please
the uh go logging on to the extranet
site as i've tried a couple of times
yesterday and today
the agenda and the minutes are not there
so i've been able to download the pack
obviously that we got on the invitation
email
but when you actually go directly onto
the extranet they're not there
whether that's a problem with my machine
or not i don't know
if i could leave that with you nick
please thank you chair
certainly yeah
can't hear you mr tucker i can't hear
you
that's better i'm turned on now right
there's one point i want to make on the
front
of the pack that says in brackets
chairman
did we not believe that should you just
say chair at the last meeting
nick yeah um
the the changes um edits to the
constitution
which have been made um the
um system used to create agendas is a
different thing and
um obviously there are places you know
all over the place that we'll have to
edit as we as we go or in due course but
i'll i'll make a note to edit that after
this
i just do
that
okay um so of
me shouldn't have been agreed um
i call him mr used to
i'll introduce the report now
so um right uh we took
the report members will remember that we
reviewed the
uh limited questions uh our previous
meetings
and that would then take into the
december council meeting
that council meeting it was decided to
withdraw the item
and ask that you referred back to the
constitution of the working party
to allow us to as a working party to
consider the issue
of supplementary questions for members
of the public
and the right to appeal against rejected
questions uh as a result of that i'm not
going to
uh go over the um word limit i think
we've all talked about that to
add into an item uh there's no value in
looking over good
again so i will just concentrate on the
supplementaries and the right
appeals um so first of all
uh we'll talk about the supplementary
questions for members of the public
uh we've looked at uh all of the uh
council's intent
and of the twelve councils inclusive of
the planet
uh five councils allow members of the
public to are subsequently talking about
questions and seven
don't uh of those five councils uh it
was unanimously
um the way that uh the the supplementary
question asked by the member public had
to relate back
directly to the question that was
originally asked so you couldn't then
sort of
um hijack or surprise the cabinet member
that was
asking about something totally different
to the subject that you're talking about
um and also the chair of the accountant
had the ability to reject or disallow
any of the sacramental questions that
uh either didn't comply with that rule
uh or were um simply just an extension
of uh not my extension i'm sorry i
apologize
uh a reaction to the answer to the
question that they just asked
um because i think that can be quite
tempting
um uh members of the public for the
greatest respect
in public um are not trained to be
counsellors and are not
trained to act like counsellors and
neither are they a political entity
in the sense that uh members of council
will
appreciate the fact that um not
answering a question
it can be a physical act um whereas a
member of the public may not realize
that um and so
it would be disappointing for them to
waste their
two minutes of time to or sorry a minute
of time to
respond to the question by putting a
supplementary by just simply making a
statement saying well i don't think that
answered my question
because that's not really going to add
any value to anything really
um we also need to be mindful of the
fact that
um the timing for this i think if we
are going to do it or members kind of
wish to consider doing this
should be the same as the um
the supplementary question rules for
members of the council because obviously
we don't want to have
a diversion to rules on that basis uh it
should be the same for both
and then the last point i'd like to make
on the supplementary questions
is the um just be mindful of the fact
that by adding a supplementary question
this can uh increase the amount of time
it takes for an individual questionnaire
to complete their turn
per se so uh original question answered
from a cabinet member
supplementary question answer from a
cabinet member
um that will then um increase
each person's turn and
sorry to interrupt nick um just i think
we've lost mr tafa here he is he's back
thanks
with the fact that you're going to
increase the total number of
words allowed for questions so questions
are going to be longer
and then you're going to allow people to
ask them to questions on top of that
which are both absolutely reasonable
that's fine but just bearing in mind
that the fact the total length of
questions
allowed is 30 minutes um
if you wanted to recommend an increase
in that
i would just sort of say that actually
you need to bear in mind that
council meetings are there to conduct
business they're not there as a
as an opportunity to be a massive
question and answer the session for
members of the public
if that's what some if that's what
council wants to do then that's
something that they could be looked into
separately about doing some other type
of question and answer session
um you don't want to be going to a
council meeting whereby the
vast majority of the meeting would then
be taken up with council questions
uh because there is other important work
that council does
and and that shouldn't be distracted
upon
moving on to the right of appeal against
rejected questions
um democratic services have again
reviewed the processes of all
councils in kent um and of those 12
no council allows any sort of
appeal against the rejection of a
question
and that's either for councillors or for
members of the public
um on top of that i think i've
raised a number of points in the in the
report and um
i don't want members to think that these
are excuses but i think they are
important that need to be taken into
account
uh which is that currently the deadline
for questions
is five working days in advance of the
meeting
now if any appeals process would then
have to operate within
what is already quite a short amount of
time
um so if you then had a
an appeals process what would the
deadline be
that will then reduce the amount of time
for um
well it will take i'd say at least a day
to two days
for there to be an appeals process um
you then have a very short window of
time to write the answers develop the
answers consult with members of the
cabinet who are answering them
which again is is the current five
cleared working days time level
is already quite short and in comparison
with a lot of other councils
we already have a very generous deadline
with regards to how late people can
submit questions to us
um
and the other thing i would say is who
would be the person that actually
administers
or considers an appeal the questions are
already considered and approved against
the relevant criteria by our chief
executive
though would that then be maybe the
chairman
or would that then be maybe another look
by the chief executive or the monitoring
officer perhaps
and also what is the basis for an appeal
which i think is probably one of the
bigger questions which is
if if somebody says well i don't like
the fact that you've
um rejected the question that's not
really a valid demands for appeal
again another one is is oh it relates to
a planning application well either it
does or it doesn't
that it's not that i always get this too
confused
subjective or objective it's not it's
not a choice
whether it um relates to a uh
a playing occasion either it does or it
doesn't uh so again that's something
else that needs to be
uh taken into account and then lastly i
would just say the fact that actually
we've a little bit in paragraph 4.4
there that
we've had 34 questions from members of
public and councillors
since the 1st january 2020 so a little
over a year
27 of those were accepted of the seven
that rejected three were about ongoing
planning applications
three were vexatious and one was
substantially similar now
i could really only see that four of
those the vexatious ones and the
substantially similar
could really in theory be could be
appealed against and as a result of that
that's not a massive percentage so
i think that it's maybe it's a
sledgehammer to crack a nut
i think one of the things that we would
like to try and encourage members of the
public to do is that
democratic services will always work
with a member of the public or a
councillor to help draft the question
or if there's any issues with the
question we can go back to them to say
actually this doesn't work but actually
if you tweet this bit then
that would make it a valid question um
so we're there to help
people in the sense of a creating and
crafting question that asks
or achieves what they want to ask but in
language that allows them
to ask it um and then
the reason that that doesn't happen more
often is because people generally tend
to leave
questions right to the last minute they
leave it until five o'clock on the day
of submission
which then doesn't leave us enough time
to help craft the question
um and help them to um to get that
question accepted
if and this is not a public blaming
thing at all it's it's just generally
and same applies for counselors as well
if if
everybody was more sort of timely with
their answering of question or
submission of questions
we would be able to help people craft
questions that would allow them not to
be
ambiguous to the point where they're
rejected so i think that
again would help as well so um
with regards to the two points we've
made um we think that there's
a reasonable amount of evidence either
way whether members wanted to
allow supplementary questions that's
fine but
we don't feel that there's really enough
evidence for us to change the current
question system
with regards to an appeals process but
that's our opinion
uh happy to have a chat about it uh i'll
pass you back to
the chairman
councillor tomlinson you've indicated
you wish to ask a question
uh yes thank you chair um and thank you
nick for your report which uh
i've got beside me here very technical i
am now i've got two computers uh
but i haven't read it before um uh
and i think nick with the tony your
voice there a little bit and i hope you
don't mind me saying this to
you um regarding um
obviously public have the right um the
agreement of extra time
as you said that's all gone through and
they're going to get that with the
supplementary
i feel that could
looking at over the years um
the question comes in um
you know the person stands up on the
normally on the
top bench normally something to have a
go at
the council not always
but the majority of times
a member of public come along they want
to have a go
now obviously they can be answered as we
all know in different ways whether it's
email or whether it's answered directly
this is me um i feel if they're given
the opportunity
to come back and obviously this is what
this is
there i feel they might even
go further and damage the reputation
of the authority and we you know i'm
being quite honest we know
those people are out there and we see
them on social media
uh far too often um uh
that that is my feeling i am as it is at
the moment i've said
the word in when people speak good that
is better but supplementaries i i
i can't personally go along with
uh and i totally understand um chair
um the extra work that would have to
come in
by someone and we all know you know the
present time
uh staffing is difficult um you know for
pills or something like that
um yeah i can see that being
what do you appeal on all the that side
of it
but say i do have concerns thank you
chap
thank you councillor thompson i've got a
list of people who wish to speak
counselor heart
thank you chair um i've got a couple of
comments um
i think uh councillor tomlinson's very
correct in the supplementaries and i
think it is a slight issue
um what i would suggest possibly
is that because we've given people an
extra
amount of time to speak and increase
their word limit
that that should be adequate for the
questions that are going to be asked
and that maybe in a year's time or 18
months time we look at the
supplementaries again
to see how we're coping with the extra
time taken to ask the questions
and whether things have changed slightly
and because the questions are maybe
getting
slightly more complicated uh because of
the extra time allowed
that supplementaries maybe or may not be
allowed and i think that's something we
should review again in say 18 months
time
um with regards to the opinion of
questions
um i totally agree that we shouldn't
that i don't think people should be
allowed to appeal
however i feel that as the chief
executive has the um and if
correct me if i'm wrong has the total
sway
as to whether that question is asked or
not
um i believe that if she decides a
question
is not to be heard or asked then that
should be judged by somebody else to
make sure
that that is um the correct procedure
and that's what i've then got to say and
i think you know i'd like another
comment on that really because i think
appeals i don't think should necessarily
as as nicholas
very rightly says um they're too close
to the date and it's just not going to
work however i think
one person having the um overall ruling
of that question
is slightly uh or could be slightly
misconstrued
in the wrong way that's all i've got to
say if
anybody'd like to come back on that i've
been very grateful thank you
thank you for that mr hughes can i ask
you just to take make a note there's a
couple more
questions to be raised and answer them
all at the same time
if that's okay nick yeah
okay i called mr lee welbeck
yeah um yeah just a question on the the
process
of um rejected questions
um i mean so far i've i've not seen
you know the the question and answer
process in in full detail in any shape
or form
but if someone does have a question
rejected
are they given any notification as to
the reason for the rejection
which presumably may allow them to
either you know
either think think again about the
question and resubmit in a different
form
or give them some reasoning as to to you
know what why it is not it is not a
valid question for council
okay that's another one for mr hughes
joanne of course
councillor piper i understand you wish
to raise a question
thank you chair um just to whiz through
all those
uh those things i think it is
of paramount importance that any
questions that are asked need to be
succinct
and to the point to enable business
to be done not just that evening but the
business of dealing with that question
especially if it requires a a fuller
written answer perhaps at a later date
or
referral on to cabinet or something like
that
it's worth us remembering of course the
public can always write
to a cabinet member or a senior officer
of the council
at any time they don't have to wait for
a council meeting
um i've written here public questions
should be in my view substantive and
largely in the public interest
possibly on larger issues
uh more complex issues rather than a
focused issue
that may only concern a few people for
example in
a small cul-de-sac if there's a a
planning application going on down there
full council it seems to me is not
really the place
to air that kind of discussion there is
of course planning committees where
things like that can be done
but so that's it really i i wouldn't
support supplementary questions for
reasons that have already been said
and i wouldn't support appeals either i
really want to focus on succinct to the
point
and of real public interest rather than
individual interest because
individual interests can be dealt with
by letter to cabinet
uh members whoever they might be or to
the right officer depending on
what the issue is thank you chet okay
thank you council piper
finally councillor hopkinson
thank you chair um firstly on the um
the uh issue of appeals so i take the
point that it's it's difficult to do
that within the uh
the time scale given the deadline we
currently operate with
well i do agree with uh councillor hart
and mr welbrook about
um the fact it'd be nice to have some
kind of uh
secondary you know another pair of eyes
on the decision
and that could be done you know over
it doesn't have to be done you know uh
before that the the council meeting in
question so
i'm not sure what exact format that
might take but i do agree
that okay yeah perhaps an appeal process
won't work but at least
someone having oversight of that um
might be
a good idea on the quote on the issue of
supplementary questions
um i have to say that i i respectfully
take a different view to uh those have
been expressed so far
um in that i actually i remembered i
think one of the first
full council meetings i i went to it
struck me that actually uh supplementary
questions would be a good idea because
um if you know if a member of the public
feels that a question hasn't been um
addressed satisfactorily or if what the
cabinet member says raises another
question then i really think
um that it's actually quite a
significant uh democratic principle to
let them
ask a further question on that and i
also think that it just increased the
general sense of um
democratizing the council and you know
rightly or wrongly i do think there
remains
a perception i'm not saying it's a fair
perception but a perception that
uh tdc can improve the extent to which
it it consults with the public and
for me personally as i say for a while
now i've held the view that actually
supplementary question would
make sense and would be a good point out
so just to
to to address some of the counterpoints
against that
um given that we have 30 minutes in
total
for questions from members of the public
if i understand correctly
then that then that it won't increase
the
the length of time for a council meeting
and so it won't affect any other
business
um and on the issue i also take the
point from councillor tomlinson i think
council the heart referred to this as
well that
you you could get questions where
you know the intent perhaps is we might
judge to be
perhaps a bit more negative than we'd
like
um but i do but i think i wouldn't be
overly concerned with that because
you've got two filtering processes one
is that the chief executive has to
okay the question in the first place and
the second is and i think the report
refers this is the chair
can take some responsibility to ensure
that the supplementary question isn't
misused
so i personally take the view that
it would be a positive signal to the uh
to the uh
community that we you know we're trying
to democratize the council
um and you know what we're suggesting is
giving the sort of same right of
return to members of the public as to
councillors so i think that'll be a
positive democratizing step
and i think although i take those points
about concerns i think there are good
points
i i personally feel that they can be
mitigated and so i
i i would be in favor of the
supplementary question
thank you thank you before i ask mr
hughes i'd like to
support what council hopkinson said uh
having been
at council meetings now for a number of
years uh you see the questioner
up on the front of the
committee room they asked the question
the question is then
answered by the relevant counselor and
then they just sat there with the total
blank face well what happens next
and i think it's only right and proper
that maybe they should be entitled
to ask a supplementary question
providing it's on the subject
that the question was about originally
and that that would be my
view at this present time mr hughes can
i ask you to come back to us now with
all the queries that have been raised
uh yes sir yeah i mean
i'm i'm not gonna comment one
sorry just kicked something over sorry
about that
um um oh awesome
uh yeah sorry yes so uh i'm not going to
comment on people's comments because
obviously that's
their point of view that's absolutely
fine um
just some of the things i picked up so
um the reasons for rejection the
um the uh point that mr welbert made
so yes we would always uh so when a
member of the public
uh emails us or fills the question form
out
uh online uh that is then uh sent to us
and then we will then respond to them
say yes or no
and give the reason so that will either
be because it's vexatious
or it's too similar or we've already had
a question like this in the last six
months
um and uh
as the the point i was making earlier
which is the fact that
we would normally help people if they
come to us and say
in the response to say i'm thinking
sorry your email your question's been
rejected it's
vexatious for the public came back
example
said well why is that why what made that
uh convexatious we can then engage in
that conversation with them
and we can say actually well if you
phrased it instead of saying i don't
like
officer x i think they're inappropriate
we can tweak it in a way that says
actually well
what makes you confident about the
ability of the council to perform xyz
function or something like that
now the problem being is if if you're
going to send me
a question at 25 past five on the day of
the deadline
um i have not got the ability to be able
to engage in that sort of conversation
with somebody
um five minutes before the deadline
however if that if that question was
sent to us
a week in advance then we've got lots
and lots of time
to be able to have that that con that
conversation and
um allow us to be able to help people
craft their questions in a better way
um so that was that one um
uh the uh adding someone else for
rejection
uh you could do that i i mean uh i think
i don't know whether it's still wouldn't
want to come in on this point but i mean
you could for example
taking a a name out of the air is that
you
could have it out in consultation with
the chairman
uh as that uh as he is uh in a political
role in the sense of the meeting so
um it would be for the chief executive
to continue to accept questions
and reject them for um the
the uh the distinct reasons uh in the
sense of it's about my application
well it is or isn't about buying
application it is or it isn't
been asked in the last six months those
those ones whereas sort of a bit of
uh it's objectivity isn't it
where people got choice i said oh i get
confused with those
or is it subjective it's the other one
it's subject subjective sorry yeah so
where it's a subjective choice so it's
about vexatiousness
or uh it's otherwise inappropriate you
could in theory say actually if we
wanted to reject these then
the checklist could reject them in
consultation with
the chairman if that made people feel a
bit more comfortable about it if they
wanted a certain opinion or something
like that
just pass them to estelle at this point
if that's okay sorry yeah estella and
this time you wish to make a comment
yes thank you chair um thanks nick uh
i'm only commenting just supporting what
nick says
um you could do that you could have in
consultation with
the chair um the opportunity is
this uh provisional negative has the
final saying isn't
an appropriate question it's very common
it's
it worked out that many but quite it's
all in the chief executive's role to
do finally on the issue but that's not
to say that actually the chief
activity on his or her own i mean mostly
or from the managing officer or for me
uh
you know particularly if it's not
clear-cut um but it's just
you know her name is the figurehead if
you like
um so i just make that point uh if it
gives people in comfort that actually
it's probably more of a it's probably
more of a
thought out process than it looks like
for the bald statement in the
constitution
does that make sense i think that's
right i think i'm sorry
nick can before you comment nick i
understand
he's having problems hearing estelle
councillor robkinson that's right i
didn't i caught about 75
of that so if i'm if i understand
rightly i think
yeah you were saying that um in fact the
chief executive officer makes these
decisions in liaison with the
democratic services is that right yes i
mean though she can't make
decisions herself she's far too busy so
it's it's normally
you know nick who's or one of his
colleagues who are enormously
experienced or my self
um you know would look at it and well
actually these questions
you know positions in the list and you
know we've made that recommendation
you know do you agree madeline and
you'll normally say yes or no i think
that's generally how it works
um but you know there has to obviously
be a
senior figurehead in the constitution
making that decision
and every other council i've worked at
is always been the chief executive
whereas the final say
they say
you keep breaking up estelle i think
that's what it is but i think
counteroptics and got the gist of it
councillor
can i just ask one question when you're
saying chair you're talking about chair
of the council
correct right nick would you like to
come back to us
to what sellers just said
no i don't think it's it's entirely
concurring with that which is that yeah
the standard process
is that uh us and democratic services
will look at the question
we do the standard checks we will look
and see whether or not that is
something that has been discussed in the
last six months we'll check
simple things like is it is it 50 words
or less
at the moment um because there's no
there's nothing worse than you go
through the whole process
and you say to remember the public oh
yeah that's an absolutely fine question
only to find out it's 51 words and
and then um you have to start all over
again um
so we will do the basic checks we will
look at it against the scheme we will
then send an email to the margin officer
and due productive
to say we feel that this is okay or we
don't feel it's okay
what's your decision they will then tell
us and that's how it works
um yeah if you wanted to have in
consultation with as as the point there
still making
ultimately it would be the chief
executive's responsibility to accept a
rejected question
but there's absolutely no problem having
in consultation with the
the chairman if you wanted to put that
in
um but ultimately it still it would
still have to retain
the um the ability of the chief exec to
be the person who ultimately rejects
something okay thank you for that
counselor heart
thank you chair um my only comment on
this
is that are people generally aware
that they can go to democratic services
um for the help needed in putting
forward a question
um and maybe this should be mentioned
at every council meeting that the
democratic services of the council
could aid um the wording of a question
because
that might a speed up the question
process
make sure the question is appropriate
and
make sure that we're not having so many
rejected questions
and i think if that's done then that
maybe um
in the future everything might run a
little bit quicker and a little bit
smoother
and maybe then people like nick won't
have to work so hard trying to check all
the questions and everything else
and maybe it speeds up the whole process
rather than elongates it
i don't know if there's any comment on
that thank you
could i just hold you with her for a
minute nick councillor atkinson
councillor upkinson you wish to make a
comment
yeah thank you chair um yeah i agree
with council of heart that
uh the more we do to publicize the you
know the rights and
and the way we can help the public
communicate with us the better
um and i also think just on in terms of
the clarification of the fact that
democratic services in fact helps make
decisions about whether to reject
questions
um that makes sense um but i still
wonder if it's uh because i because
there are so few questions rejected i
don't think it would be very onerous
and i do think it'd be beneficial if um
a a member of the council and you know
for example the chair as suggested
um we were able to pro to review those
at least afterwards
um um if not get uh you know be asked
for
sign off on rejections if that were the
case
if we if the chair was of the council
were to be given sign off on rejections
then
i suppose we'd also need to consider
what to do if there were a disagreement
on whether to reject or not thank you
can i ask you to come back on that nick
yeah i mean i think um
i've taken the point of the council of
hearts made first which is that uh
i'm very very grateful for you to make
me less busy that's always good thank
you very much for that
um but on a serious note um no i do
think
we could look at maybe changing or
asking the gem to change your script
slightly when we get to the check the
questions item
um and and put a plug in
if you want a better word about uh
getting in contact with us
and uh and sort of opening out the the
questioning process
we have got a uh a fantastic new website
that we've created for our questions
that includes google forms and other
exciting things
including all of the uh questions that
have ever been asked in the last
two three four years i think it is um so
members of the public can look back see
what they've
um see what questions have been asked
it's got their word for work
pretty much word for word uh answers
from from the
from the councillors uh so that's all
there uh and i think we probably could
do
a bit better in um uh plugging that i
think i think it's uh
it's a very democratic services thing to
want to sit in the background and
not shout about ourselves but um maybe
we need to um
give it more proactive than that we can
certainly take that on board
um i'm not sure that you can make it the
chairman having the final say
um i think you could certainly involve
him absolutely yeah but i do
think you'd have to remain as the chief
executive ultimately being the person
that signed it off
but having having regard to what the
chairman
says is i don't think that's a that's
not a deal breaker at all i don't think
okay just one thing is it from what
everybody's saying would it be worth
democratic services or
the council communications press office
issuing some sort of
press release for the local papers to
make the public aware of the new website
and the new
procedure that's on there from asking
questions of counsellors
uh we can certainly put some stuff on
our social media channels i'm sure i can
have a chat with our cons team about
that
excellent i think uh councillor
tomlinson wants to raise a question
yes thank you chair um i find it
interesting i know i've said
other meetings i've been here a little
while now and i feel
um if people are coming to full
council um to speak
which as we all know they have every
right to providing it is appropriate
um they will find a way um
and over the years um
i think we've seen that i know chair
you've as you've said
quite rightly so you've always sat in
the back in the public gallery when
you're allowed to
you saw how it worked um uh
i still have um let's say that that's
one point um people will find a way and
it's normally
uh as it's been touched on um a bit of a
moan
about something i like what's being said
about
planning issues because and
things like licensing uh they've come up
over the years as well as we all know um
and there are appropriate channels for
them to be dealt with
for those committees uh but i still
you know what happening on what one of
you know we're talking about this
afternoon
uh putting councillors in a spot with a
a supplementary question um again i feel
that
you know i totally understand council
lock instance what he's saying there
but i and i really do but i feel
um so i feel quite strongly that that
could put
that person um in a compromising
position
at that time and when we're
like we are now being live streamed and
so forth
um you you you've got to do your best
because the members of the public are
watching you
thank you chair thank you councillors
tomlinson
um i think the way ahead nick and please
correct me if i'm wrong
do we need a proposal for the
acceptance of supplemental questions
and a second and also a proposal in the
second
in relation to allowing appeals and
after that we you can then look at how
you're going to take other things
forward
that have been raised in the meeting
uh you can do either way german to be
honest if you want to split it out you
can do
uh the panel just needs to decide
whether it supports the idea
of supplementary questions and wants to
recommend that on to
the standards committee or whether it
doesn't want to recommend that onto a
stands committee
and likewise with the um with the
appeals process do you want to recommend
an appeals process to
standards or don't you
okay in that case can we take a recorded
vote all those that
wish a supplemental question to be
allowed could you please
let me know
against councillor tommy
vincent i'm for it chair councillor
hopkinson
council heart okay
so council heart
against chair out of the piper
i think councillor hopkinson made a good
argument
i would be for it in the sense that what
we are doing is sending it on to
standards
they will then discuss it eventually it
will come back to council and council
will make the decision
so at this point i would say yes push it
forward for further discussion
thank you very much council piper i will
take that on board for the next
standards meeting
nick we have a two to two what is the
process please
uh you you and mr welbrook get a uh
a vote as well okay lee what is your
position please uh my votes in favor of
passing on to the standards committee
for further discussion
and i totally agree with you so i think
that the supplementary question should
be recommended to standards for them to
take forward
um at the next meeting would that be
about right
i think everybody's in agreement what
about the process of appeal can we start
again
councillor tomlinson
okay against the pills
council hopkinson
um i i think just on this
is the reason i'm hesitating a bit is
because i think there was still a little
bit to iron out here i mean
i think probably on balancing i'd be
against appeals but i i i wouldn't
i was hoping we might be open to a
slightly different suggestion in terms
of how we might include the chair of the
council in the process
right and that's not an appeal but
that's
something perhaps that we could
recommend as an alternative
[Music]
can we come on to that once we've
finished with this little bit about
appeals
because i think that's something that we
need to go back yeah that's right
in that case i'll abstain on the
question of appeals
counselor piper
piper are you in favor of the
recommendation for the appeal or not
i wouldn't recommend appeals no
okay council heart
um i wouldn't recommend the pills i just
think as as
uh one of my college counselor hopkinson
said it needs to be addressed in a
certainly different way
um i don't think that we should just um
allow people to go
gangster pills i just think he needs to
go through a third you know
with somebody else checking on what is
being done by our chief exec
thinking i don't know how you're going
to put that so i'm against appeals but i
do think it needs to be
adjusted in a different way okay mr
welcome mr welbeck
um yeah i'm i'm against appeals thank
you
and i would totally agree with that as
well so we are left with the
to just sum up the meeting supplementary
questions
is going forward to be considered by
standards committee to recommend to full
council
but the appeals process won't in
relation to the other matters that have
been raised
about involving a third party i think
that falls back into democratic services
lap
is that right nick
well i think i say you're more than
welcome to put a recommendation forward
to say
we don't feel that as like it's quite
clear that you think that supplementary
questions are
worthy of further discussion but that's
actually you don't think that
um it's worth having an appeals process
but in substitution of an appeals
process
that you may want to recommend that uh
when questions are rejected
or feel as if they are going to be
rejected for one of the
subjective reasons that the
chairman of council is consulted upon by
the
uh by the executive
council thomason are you in favor of
what mr hughes has just said
yes totally understand yep to go along
with that
council hopkinson could we just uh
clarify i mean i think i am basically in
favor but could
sorry can we just clarify again exactly
what the proposal is is is the proposal
to
um that the chair of the council be
consulted
for the rejection of a question is that
right
i think that's right nick isn't it yeah
for the subjective one
so when it's a um
when it might be vexatious or when it's
um
substantially similar i think it is
there's
i don't see there's any value in in
consulting the
chairman of council because somebody
submitted a question that's 51 words
rather than 50.
that doesn't seem to be a valuable use
of their time to be honest
or whether it relates to a planning
application because either it does
relate to a buying application
or it doesn't it's one of those things
that the the basic reasons
i can't see any value in consulting but
the the more subjective ones then
you
mr welbeck
sorry i think council officials and just
wanted to clarify something so i'm happy
to uh
for you to do that yeah just want to
thank you
just wanted to say uh you know those
caveats that nick you mentioned make
sense and i
uh i agree with this proposal on the
basis of those
okay mr welbeck yep i agree as well i'm
in favor
so joe i think i still wanted to make a
comment i was just going to say i still
you wish to make a comment
uh yes sorry i hope i'm not going to
throw a spanner in the works but um just
on that point about
having a distinction between what we
might call subjective view questions and
objective view questions
i mean it's very clear if something is
longer than the question length that it
you know it doesn't fall into the
criteria for a question but as to
whether something relates or doesn't
relate to a planning application you can
get some quite sort of
um you know what's the word
esoteric questions asked where our
decision as to whether it relates to a
planning application
might differ from somebody's you asking
he's asking the question from their
assessments of what they're asking so if
you're going to propose
that um the decision on whether to
reject is is for the chief executive in
consultation with the chair
i do think particularly because we
probably don't reject that many
questions
they're either all in scope or they're
not in scope and for those that are
actually very straightforward say
because they exceed the number limit you
could just say
as we do with other things you know by
the way you know here's here's a couple
of questions that exceed the
exceed the number of words limit
or whatever it is you know they're
rejected
do you agree and and it would be just
like a tick box thing
but i do think if you start to you then
get into the arguments as to
you know well what are you not referring
to the chair or what are you referring
to the chair so i do think to make it
simpler you have to you would
wish to consider having everything in
consultation with the chair
or nothing in consultation with the
chair does that make sense
sorry i've just made nick's life more
difficult
i yes i think you're right and i think
our standards committee meeting next
week will be quite interesting
has anybody else got any views any
comments
well yeah i totally agree with what
estelle has said because i
i wasn't asked if i wanted to agree or
disagree however
i would also as i said earlier nick did
agree to the possibility
of adding um the democratic services
will help people with their questions
and word them
at the council meetings when people can
ask questions
and i think that's an important part of
it because
most people aren't aware and i think it
will
aid in a bet democratic services if
people ask for help
and that's that's council heart that's
why i suggested possibly democratic
services could
release something on social media sites
to encourage the public
to contact democratic services when they
have a question
i totally agree mr tubman you know it's
just that
it could also be mentioned that um at
uh the council meeting as well i feel
because then that might have a greater
scope
counselor piper i understand you wish to
make a comment
no it was just that um i i
in terms of the proposal i do need to
register an opinion
i suppose um i i was listening to what
uh estelle culligan said also
and what i think i heard earlier in the
discussion
the business of rejecting questions is
it seems to me has not been a single
person issue
the question has been looked at by
democratic services it's been looked at
by
members of nick's staff perhaps uh it
might have been discussed with the
monitoring officer
and so on so the idea that the ceo
suddenly gets a
pile of envelopes with questions and uh
you know
one goes in the bin one goes on the
table that's not what we've got so by
the time it gets to the ceo for an
executive decision
it's already been heavily filtered and
it seemed to me from what we heard
was that her decision
to reject sorry that's a
message um her decision to reject was
merely
a recommendation to her by members of
her team
we think this one stands we think these
ones don't
and so it's more of a um a titular
job if that makes sense that she's not
actually sitting there on her own
pontificating on the questions so i i
don't see the need to change the current
system to be honest
thank you your comments have been noted
counselor piper
has anybody else got any questions to
raise any comments to make
silence i think that mr use that
brings the meeting to a close doesn't it
yes if i can just say just summarize if
that's okay
so we are going to recommend that we
uh further converse on top launch
questions at standards
uh that we don't think that appeals
process
is a good idea uh so we won't be holding
that recommendation onto the standards
and that we think that rejections
uh of questions should be in
consultation with the chair of the
council
yes that's right and that we should ask
the chairman to amend his speech
at full council to include the fact that
if people get to us
if people submit their questions early
enough stem services can help them
in the wording and we'll do some comms
about
questions and stuff on our new website
absolutely absolutely spot-on plus also
noting
council piper's comments
can i um just check something sorry um
i don't have a um
opinion or or a for or against the
um recommendation um
the rejected questions are put to the
chair
uh from council heart or
uh you mr tucker but i i didn't
catch that for the minute
hello katie happy to go with the flow
there so that goes through the other
goes for a second uh with the chair if
you should i mean
thank you thank you well i i would agree
with that
katie if it is necessary lovely thank
you
i think that brings the meeting to a
close everybody thank you very much for
your attendance